[Music]
George's made great steps on
implementation of our association
agreements this provides the basis for
our political association and our
economic integration the European Union
is fully committed to exploring the full
potential of our partnership and
including the export and growth
potential offered by the deep and
competitive a free trade area we have in
place we also discussed the importance
of continuing the good work already done
in the area of the rule of law and for
Georgia to further strengthen its
judicial institutions in transparent
manner we support your central integrity
within your internationally recognized
borders and we are committed to peace
stability and PT we Georgia Europe has
an important success zone we are working
hard to prove the democracy promotion
institution building civil empowerment
and reforms really we promise to
continue on this path and hope that we
will be fully welcomed and contribute to
the European family
Georgia and our people have full
commitment to know the past over to the
community it is a value based choice
towards returning to
decision choice European family we also
look together at the progress made in
the implementation of our association
agreement that some of the remaining
challenges the implementation of the
great actions of the high-level meeting
between Commission and the Georgian
government which focus on economy trade
and connectivity education research and
innovation and justice as well as
internal security will further advance
our cooperation and deliver more
tangible benefits for church and
European citizens
[Music]